about a month ago I released a video
outlining 12 instances the Dragon Ball
super manga was better than the anime
and boy was it a hoot however
[Music]
so since a few people might have asked
today we're gonna dust off our totally
legitimate non digital copies I'm Dragon
Ball super manga as we count down the
twelve times Dragon Ball super anime was
better number twelve
at this point God's involvement with the
Dragon Balls story is about as solid as
Dragon Ball super future what too soon
regardless Dragon Ball super anime
really doesn't give the former fan
favorite any chance to express himself
but for those of you who have been
watching this arc know that while Dragon
Ball super for about 80 episodes didn't
give him anything meaningful to do they
most certainly are giving him something
to do in the universe survival arc going
this virus to give him on-screen time
training with piccolo as well as the
totally legitimate and important moniker
of Tim captain and wild most of us
thought it was weird and perhaps a tad
too convenient for him to regain all of
his strength in such a short period of
time at the very least the anime
actually gave him time this is what the
manga gave him yep it's much better
number 11 this one is admittedly quite
small but in all honesty I really missed
it when reading through the manga the
student master dynamic between Vegeta
and Kaaba is easily one of Dragon Ball
super best additions to the franchise as
well as Vegeta's character this being
their first occasion fighting Vegeta was
surprised to discover that kava had not
yet unlocked the Super Saiyan form and
so in the only way he knows how
proceeds to teach at Aqaba the manga and
the anime are quite similar in their
approaches with certain panels looking
almost identical to the anime
however the manga ends with Vegeta
saying nothing to kava as he delivers
that final blow whereas in the anime
this happens
remember this pain and let it activate
this is just my opinion but the anime I
thought was more in keeping with the
student master dynamic established in
the story number 10
trunks versus Goku in both versions has
a variety of similarities they even have
the same narrative goals trunks showing
Goku what it's like to face off against
black and Goku demonstrating how much
they got this in regards to when they
eventually face black the two Saiyans
begin to fight as Super Saiyan 2 as the
fight presses on
Goku further transforms into Super
Saiyan 3 to demonstrate the trunks how
much farther he is still to go as a
fighter
however and this is where the manga and
the super anime differ in the anime Goku
slams trunks to the floor has a Super
Saiyan 3 overpowering in the manga
trunks increases his level to the
neighborhood office Super Saiyan 3 while
still retaining his Super Saiyan to form
Goku then has to resort to using his God
form to knock him out daddy this is a
difficult one to decide which is better
as I believe they both should have
switched media sources Toyota Rose story
would have worked better with the animes
version of this fight and the anime
would have done much better with Devon
Guzman with that said however I
personally found the animes version of
the events a little easier to stomach
though this isn't the last time I'll
mention trunks involvement in this
countdown number 9 this entry is one
that will begin a trend while many might
prefer the mangas interpretation of
events more or perhaps it's writing it's
hard to dispute that when super does
produce a quality episode it's gorgeous
and this is easily one of the most
beautiful fights in one of the most
visually stunning episodes when it comes
to storyboarding background art and
animation the manga had a nice fight
between the two but the anime delivered
a fight that really stands out amidst
the rest of the series and while I
really appreciate three or Taro's
efforts to try and bring this scene to
life I adored the animes interpretation
just that little bit more from a visual
standpoint number eight this fight
suffers from an enormous problem one the
manga endures on more than one occasion
but before I get into that I want to
make one thing perfectly clear I was not
happy when I found out that super was
going to be recapping the movies it was
a boring idea and resulted in many
tuning out of the show for a long period
of time but with that said if the
higher-ups make the decision to redo the
movies one should do their best to make
it as good and interesting as they can
and while the mango looks more
consistent visually speaking the anime
differs of much more in terms of variety
in the action sequences particularly
during the beerus versus goku fight in
the anime that fight takes up four whole
episodes with some toting it as being
better than the movies fight in some
instances the mangas interpretation of
the events is covered in 11 pages not
very long at all and offers little
different from the movies version the
mangas retelling on these events seems
disinterested and boring compared to the
animes telling numbers said this is a
similar crime to the previous entry only
much more severe I don't know if Cleo
taro hated this AK or what but he had
the fast-forward button on a lot of
these scenes why bother to cover an arc
if you're not going to cover it with
care anyway one of the most important
moments in the movie was the discovery
of the Super Saiyan God transformation
and actually performing the ritual on
Goku the animées have decided entire
episode for this as they should it's a
pretty big deal the manga on the other
hand covers the summoning of Shenron
asking him about the Super Saiyan God
the announcement of Adele's pregnancy
the performance of the Super Saiyan God
ritual and Goku's transformation in a
Warren Page this not only serves to make
the forum feel less sensational but also
doesn't encourage readers to keep
reading the battle of gods chapters of
the manga are easily the weakest in the
series number 6 with an arc called the
Future Trunks arc you would like to
think that trunks plays a more active
role in the story but once Goku and
Vegeta get their hands on black for the
first time trunks is hardly ever seen I
will say that he does play a role in the
story but it would have been nice to see
him doing even a little bit more to help
the effort and while the anime isn't
perfect and has its problems it's also
very satisfying in my opinion to see
Trump stand up and fight for the world
he is the
fender up number five this one might be
a little controversial so let me say
that I liked both versions of this fight
up front but the anime's version of
vegeto versus fuse imasu was much better
in my opinion while I will concede the
prelude to the mangas confrontation is
more compelling utilizing Vegeta's love
for palma to initiate the fusion itself
the anime really runs away with this
scene once the fists start being thrown
while the animes fight with Vegeta
wasn't exactly long-lived the mangas
version only lasted 10 pages or so on
top of that didn't feature the final of
Kamehameha despite them teasing it all
in all the a may achieved a much more
spectacular series of events during the
fight making it much more compelling in
my opinion despite beginning and ending
in the same spot number 4 if there is
any way I can work this into a video
you'll be damn sure I'll find it this is
easily one of my favorite episodes in
the entire series and is in my view
horribly underrated and forgotten at
times this is the kind of episode
thirteen year old me would have gone
crazy for back in the day Goku and
Vegeta training company the [ __ ] in and
while the resurrection F Ark being
skipped was largely a saving grace for
the manga it missed out on opportunities
to have fun light-hearted antics like
episode 18 hat
screw it I'm gonna go watch that episode
again number 3 Dragon Ball super I feel
has made a name for itself by having
some of the best filler material in the
entire sea of Dragon Ball with episodes
like Goku vs. hit the rematch the PO
tofu Ark and the baseball episode it's
easy to see why but for this entry I
want to draw attention to my favorite
minier the two-part story of Crillon
rekindling his fighting spirit found in
episode 75 and 76 these two are some of
my favorites produced by Dragon Ball
super episode 75 especially has some
wonderful art direction as well as some
stellar character moments for Curlin
however the scene that stayed with me
long after came in episode 76 when faced
with combating all of these intimidating
illusions Goku and krillen share a short
dialogue together
kinda
I found this seem to be heartbreaking
arguably my favorite curling moment
number two you guys definitely saw this
one coming
heck I'm even sure some of you thought
this was going to be my number one when
it's not but it is an outstanding scene
nonetheless while the manga covered the
nitty gritty details much better than
the animated in terms of sheer spectacle
the anime is far and above the better of
the two in my view at the end of the day
people don't remember Dragonball for its
airtight storytelling and nuanced
characters they likely remember it for
its bombastic battle sequences I would
also consider this to be an incredibly
important scene one that's super at the
time sorely needed to its name it's
incredible it's intense and it put
Dragonball super back in the minds of
many people number one this had to be my
number one how could it not be this is
easily my favorite collection of scenes
in all of Dragon Ball super and they
took it out of the manga I absolutely
adore these types of character
interactions in fact this was the moment
that inspired me to make this video I
just had to wait for the manga chapter
to be released which covered this and
when it did I was so disappointed the
manga decided to completely gloss over
pretty much the entire interaction with
Frieza
we only hear about what happened through
dialogue later hardly a fitting
substitute the animes version saw a
gripping negotiation between Frieza and
Goku the resurrection of the evil
emperor and his annihilation of the
assassins sent to destroy him not
forgetting his escape from a god of
destruction Sakai his plan to overthrow
the gods and his quick but incredible
fight with Goku when you're reading that
chapter of the manga you can't help but
feel there are two stories going on and
you're watching and reading through the
boring one so if I'm being perfectly
honest if the anime had followed the
manga in this instance I wouldn't have
been pumped to see the tournament of
power but that's just my opinion
what's yours leave a comment down below
I'd love to know what you think did I
get a writer was AI weiwei off since the
news hit mere hours after my last video
was uploaded many of you have asked it
had been worried about whether or not
I'll keep my regular uploads going after
super ends in my
and to answer that question absolutely I
never did this YouTube thing for views
or for money I made make and will
continue to make videos because it's fun
it's been an amazing year for me and
honestly it blows my mind that you guys
get a kick out of watching these videos
I'm a so I'm not going anywhere I hope
you enjoyed this video I've been totally
not mark and as I've always said thank
you so much for watching I'll see you
next week